mettons nous à la place de celui qui
cultive et qui n'est pas sûr de récolter
est ce que notre société accepterait que
le fruit de son travail puisse
disparaître sous jamais fait de grêle ou
un effet de sécheresse et d'être obligé
de recommencer l'année d'après tout en
ayant le même risque possible et donc
que je pense qu'on a besoin de remettre
devant le sens national et bien l'esprit
de solidarité que nous avons besoin et
surtout de soutenir nos agriculteurs qui
ne nous l'oublions pas nous nourrissent
tous les jours
[Musique]
les sinistres ont augmenté de façon
importante surtout qu'on connaît de gros
sinistres verdejo sécheresse les grosses
périodes de gel donc ce qui amplifie le
phénomène et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
a besoin de se reposer la question de
savoir comment on fait évoluer les
systèmes qui existaient comme le système
des calamités qui existait depuis 1964
[Musique]
alors l'assurance récolte j'aurais envie
de dire directement pour les
agriculteurs et indirectement pour tous
les français directement pour les
agriculteurs parce qu'on a besoin de
pouvoir apporter un soutien aux
agriculteurs qui connaissent les aléas
climatiques depuis déjà des décennies et
qu'il les voit de façon croissante avec
l'évolution du climat et puis j'aurais
envie de dire pour tous les français
parce que chaque aléa climatique s'il
n'y avait pas une possibilité de
soutenir ces filières qui vont être en
difficulté ou qui sont déjà en
difficulté par rapport à quelques aléas
par exemple le gel du mois d'avril de
l'année dernière eh bien les français ne
connaîtraient plus certaines filières de
production donc on perdrait une fois de
plus et encore plus nous tourmenter
alimentaire
[Musique]
le changement du sénat est de passer un
projet de loi d'orientation ce qui lui
donne une ampleur plus grande et ce qui
permet de pouvoir introduire certains
paramètres qui sont importants le
deuxième élément c'est dans ces
paramètres d'avoir inscrit à l'article 1
le montant du budget qui avait été
annoncé tant pour le président de la
république par le ministre en septembre
2021 de 600 millions d'euros
il était important que ce soient
sanctuarisés dans la loi et que ce
montant soit clairement évité le
troisième élément c'est que nous avons
introduit des taux dans la loi qui
correspondent donc aux toute franchise
au taux de subvention de la partie
assurantielle mais aussi aux seuils
d'intervention de la solidarité
nationale il me semblait important pour
apporter la confiance et permettre aux
dispositifs de se développer au niveau
des agriculteurs que de donner un
message clair qu'ils puissent donner
clairement les chiffres et les montants
de ses différents des différents seuils
aux différentes au puy le dernier
élément qui apporte de la lisibilité qui
permettra je l'espère au début le
dispositif de se développer puisque nous
nous cachons pas l'idée de ce dispositif
c'est de l'être le plus séduisant pour
les agriculteurs de façon à ce qu'un
maximum d'agriculteurs s'assurer rentrer
dans le vif positif et donc nous avons
introduit plus réalise lui à l'it et des
taux c'est à dire que l'étau qui seront
indiqués selon l'indicatif que nous
avons mis dans la loi et bien devront
subsister pendant trois ans sans être
modifiée
[Musique]